[Music]
we are definitely the games are becoming
quite a bit more advanced
and again i want to repeat that
my commentary
during the games generally tends to
mirror the level that i'm at and so i
don't rehash some of the basics in the
opening and often you'll see me going
through the opening quite a bit faster
and not
asking people to tell me the moves and
that's calculated that's you know the
whole the whole point really
which is to give us more time to focus
on those moments which are interesting
to the level that i'm currently at thank
you cpt flunkers
i also hope we play a human today we're
not successful in that regard yesterday
e4 b6 okay so we faced this once or
twice
and there are many good setups here but
you know those are the particularly
sharp memory might remember the setup
that i've that i adopted previously
which i really like
and that is so not f3 now you guys are
confusing this with uh
c3 bishop d3
which is what we play against g6 here f3
is really weakening and
violates ben feingold's rule no first we
play simply we play knight c3
but in this position so we don't play a3
black obviously wants bishop b4
but the way that we neutralize it is we
go bishop out to d3
and then in response to bishop before we
go knight e2 knight g duo there's only
one knight that can go to e2
the point is is obviously that after a3
bishop to c3 we can recapture with the
other knight and preserve our pawn
structure and keep our e4 pawn very
nicely defended so white is just solidly
better in this position we already have
the two bishops we've got a great
position
and we can handle this great position in
several different ways the simplest move
is to castle
but probably a little bit more ambitious
more ambitious and more annoying for
black is the move bishop g5
because it already threatens e5
and we're basically
the the effectiveness of bishop g5
uh it increases when black is not as
well developed because black doesn't
have as many resources to deal with
the threat of e5 right so d6 doesn't
help if black moves the queen away then
bishop takes f6
okay d6
doesn't help
does it help i don't think it helps
still go e5
we're already winning
takes takes and bishop g2 obviously is
literally
actually very counterproductive this
even makes it worse because it opens up
the g file first what should we do
there's a million winning moves here
what should we play
what's the simplest move
just to show how winning we are i think
you're just knocks for five rook two one
just just we don't need to take with a
new sacrifice shrinking one
everything is hanging black loses every
piece on the board
and gets
mated
this is resignable
but this is why i don't recommend
playing
these sidelines until you're really you
know like a master almost and even then
you shouldn't play them as your main
opening
and you can rack up a ton of points by
you know by by having good setups ready
against these lines now here again there
are multiple wins
but the most clinical is well what is
the most clinical who can tell me
not bishop h4 at this point we can start
acting
so the point here is not to win the
maximal number of minor pieces it's to
deliver checkmates deliver checkmate
uh the puzzle pieces fall into place we
need to open the g file and then we need
to get the queen to h5 now in order to
do both things we need to eliminate that
knight and get black to take with the
pawn
and then rook takes g2 check and then
queen h5 queen takes h6's unstoppable
mate we can pre-move queen takes h6 but
we won't
no this setup is great at bishop d392
incredibly good setup
people don't know what to do against it
people don't know what to do against it
yeah
so
this setup is is monster um
now is this set up winning by force
obviously not black has ways to deal
with it
in particular um
so i actually think yeah so here
i think the move for black is
yeah so here i don't think black should
take on e7 and probably here the move is
d5
d5 and if e5
there's an interesting move that some
people play here which is bishop back to
f8
in order to be able to play c5 and so
that the bishop doesn't get caught in
front of the pawns and then potentially
trapped this is similar to a french and
guess what white plays find knight b1
eight games in order to be able to play
c3 so this is some sort of
really weird transposition to
a french where white is definitely up
like a tempo or two
so
i'm not enthralled with the setup from
black's perspective
but the second improvement was to go
bishop e7 here black has to keep this
bishop i mean without the dark squared
bishop bishop g5 becomes such a big
problem
and we've been talking a lot about you
know how to evaluate pins when are pins
dangerous
well pins you know this
doesn't fulfill
the main category that makes pins
dangerous does anybody remember what
that is like what is the simplest
shorthand for determining whether a pin
is
really dangerous or not yeah whether the
pinned piece is defended by a pawn
and it is
but the issue is that first of all black
doesn't have a dark scored bishop to put
on e7
second of all black is already castled
to the same side where he is pinned so
moving the queen is not really an option
and third of all for the very same
reason h6 g5 which is usually a very
trusted emergency method
is suicidal here because like white's
going to go h4 and just look at black's
king here i mean this is just
totally unthinkable why it's crushing
here
so the game is almost over after bishop
g5 i know it sounds weird but it almost
is
what if d6 and ipd7 where i'm not sure
where i mean he played knight d6 and we
played e5 and we won
now one more thing if black goes
uh h6
there is a forced win here which is
quite nice
does anybody see it
bishop h4 g5 is the idea that also wins
for white
but an elegant win here thank you
thirsty monster for the raid a very
elegant win here
is to play
he takes f6
and then after hg5 queen h5
do you see the point
mate is threatened and if black goes g6
obviously bishop takes g6
and that's it the game is over
easy
all of this is very simple
or
with a similar concept you could play
bishop h4 g5 ef
and this is an anchor anchor pawn and
you get the queen to g7
lots of different ways to win
that's about it i mean
very dubious setup for black and
our opponent got punished any questions
uh well probably not totally losing i
think if black had gone h6 here maybe
they would have survived would have
survived but d6
maybe maybe d6 first to be able to go e5
but
it's already very bad yes brandon
okay reg 9999
a reg
okay 45 knight f3 knight c6 let's see
what we're facing here we haven't faced
this is might be the first roy lopez
that we faced
now there's so many lines that
we could play against the buzz
um
but
the default is the main line i don't see
a reason not to go for the main line
let's go a6
and of course
and and now knight f6 the a6 is
technically called the morphe defense
morphe was the first
to figure this move out
now you go knight f6
and now
there are again multiple variations you
could play knight takes e4 that's the
open rui
you could play
b5 and bishop c5 that's the archangel
but again the main move here is bishop
modestly developing to e7
okay so now it's very important not to
castle a lot of people when they're
first starting to play e5 they make this
mistake why is castles wrong here we
have to play b5 this is the time to play
b5
yeah it's a free pawn so rookie 1
defends e4 which means that bishop takes
c6 and 95 is now a threat
which means that you have to intercept
the bishop
and in the previous speedrun we played
the marshall attack which i think i want
to play again so
at this point there's one more fork in
the road
black can go d6 here
but
marshall developed a really interesting
system where
black castle's here
and in response to c3 which is white's
main move
we play the marshall
gambit which is d5
with the marshall attack i'm kind of
blanking on
what it's formally called it takes d5 we
had one other speedrun game with this
so we sacked the pawn
and our opponent are confidently going
for the main line what should we do here
what is the move does anybody remember
or no
so bishop b7 is the old move marshall
used to play bishop b7 not considered
good anymore the move is c6
supporting the knight on d5
then white's response is d4
now we need to get this rook off of e5
and we need to get our pieces onto the
king side as with all gambits if we let
white develop the queen side and
consolidate we're just going to be down
a pawn
so we start with bishop d6 and then we
go queen h4 in response to rookie 1.
yeah our opponent so far demonstrating
full knowledge of all of the theory
which is impressive but
understandable from the 1700 and now
queen h3 bishop e3 yep that's correct
wow okay wait is that correct let me
now if full disclosure i myself don't
it's been a while since i played the
marshall so
i'm not sharp on the theory i wasn't
expecting our opponent to
reproduce all of the main moves
i think the move here if i remember
correctly is bishop f5 we need to get
our bishop out
yeah it's very easy to forget the moves
here i think bishop f5 is the move
potentially threatening bishop e4
and then of course we also want to get a
rook into the picture
uh bishop g4 i think there's queen d3
and queen f1 i'll show after the game
yeah so like if we go bishop e4 here
we run into queen f1
slightly annoying
no bishop before queen f1 is not winning
i think we need to get our rook into the
game first rook e8
fin f1 anyway
now in the marshall sometimes you can
trade queens that doesn't mean there's
no compensation anymore but in this
particular instance
there's no need to trade we can drop our
queen back to h5 keep controlling the
white squares
and continue to probe knight d2
now again if i remember correctly
there's a crazy move here
there's this move g5 in certain
positions
um
but i don't remember if you're supposed
to play it here
wow i'm shocked our opponent knows this
bishop h3 bishop d1 idea
i think g5 is the move
i think g5 is the move the point is like
controlling more squares
and potentially preparing
some sacrifice enough
okay i'm gonna be i promise to be honest
yesterday
so i'm gonna be honest i'm already
sussed i'm sussed out already but
um we're gonna keep playing
let's go knight f4
let's see what happens
let's sacrifice our knight try to open
the g file
okay but the problem is again i bring
this up and then that's all people talk
about for the rest of the game
so
i didn't say i think he's cheating i
think i said this is unusual
it's unusual for a 1700 to know this
much theory in the red lopez that's all
i'm saying
that's all i'm saying
it's entirely possible that this guy
studied it a week ago and
this is totally unfounded
i'm not randomly sacking a knight this
isn't even a sack
gfgf and the bishop is trapped if you
look into this more carefully you'll see
that it's not really even a sacrifice
yeah exactly there's plenty of seventeen
hundred to know this without this line
it's just unusual that's
that's all but the next couple of moves
are gonna be quite revealing bishop
takes f4
well
we played gf4 now we try to use this
pawn to to shatter
the king position take stakes and i
guess rookie one is very strong
here i don't really want to trade i mean
i'm getting outplayed
guess we can move our rook to the side
yeah i guess now knight e4 is very
strong
no black is worse i messed up somewhere
i'm sorry
that's why i should i shouldn't play
stuff in the speedrun that i don't know
very well
no i think i think he's legit i just
think i just think i messed up
a move and
takes ian and rookie one is a pretty
simple idea
so what's going on in this position well
we're down upon still we've got active
pieces on the king's side
um
the issue is that our king is quite weak
there's weak squares around the board
like f6 is a weak square
there's tension on the queen side
white's got this open
bile
we've got a passive rook so one idea
how do we activate the rook what idea am
i thinking about here to to try to get
at least something going in the
direction of white's king this is a
classic concept okay a b will play a b
yeah king h8 rook g you got to be aware
of this idea bishop d1 okay
so this attacks the queen where should
we go well h6 or g6 probably let's let's
go to g6 that just seems like the most
reasonable square
right
bishop f3
maneuver
it's an impressive maneuver bishop b3 d1
f3
um
okay
so this is kind of a threat although we
could probably ignore it
maybe c5 is interesting
yeah let's go c5 let's try to complicate
the game try to get this bishop active
yeah i thought this didn't work but now
i see that it does see what i thought i
could do i thought i could sack on g3
but no
how foolish of me to think so
the marshall is a good opening if you
know it very well
well okay wait i have an idea here i
think he might have messed up
i think he might have messed up guys
you know what my what is my idea well
there's not many many options here
well it's a check it's a check it's a
check
the move is is king g7 so the point is
we're threatening gh
and then bishop d3 check winning the
queen
if king f1 if king h1 there's a mate on
g1
and if hg now
then what's our move
then what's our move
wait no i think i think he's lost the
thread completely fork boom boom same
diagonal
right
boom
strange play yeah
i don't know what to make of this
i think this wins for black
no obviously this means that this guy
was legit
just knows openings
bishop c6
okay
well we're definitely winning now let me
think so we can we can
take this rook with either the rook or
the bishop
okay i have an idea
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
take with the bishop
and how am i thinking about this
resulting position
so
what do i notice here well i notice the
fact that after bishop takes c8 that
bishop on e8 is incredibly vulnerable to
type 2 undefended piece
the knight on d2 is a type 1 undefended
piece and the king is wide open
so you got to learn to put the pieces of
the puzzle together
and you know it's not it's important not
just to find forks but to find like
second order forks moves that attack an
opponent's piece and then prepare a fork
so queen e6 in this case
it's important to spot these moves
because you're preparing queen e3 chat
easy to miss about easy to miss those
kinds of moves
well movement troll if i may be totally
frank
the
the reality is that i i generally am
never worse against like
someone below 2200. now that doesn't
mean i'm not human somebody's incapable
of outplaying me
but
you know
generally if i'm playing my openings
it's
uncommon
that's all
no no no and this is not to suggest that
somebody
you know in this rating range is
incapable of outplaying me it would be a
ridiculous thing to say
but for all intents and purposes that it
is true
it's an arrogant thing to say but it's
also kind of the truth
it's just unlikely
gm's lose games but
not the 1700s
i think the comparison i would make if
people are newer to chess if you're
newer to chess watching the stream who
is this [ __ ]
who thinks he who thinks he can't lose
to anybody
and why do people like him like
a jerk
um
the comparison i would make is
yeah just calling anybody a cheater who
dares to be better against him so the
comparison i would make is
probably
an nba player
playing against
like a decent
and then okay if you want an nba team
playing against a high school varsity
team
and the high school varsity team
uh leading going into the second
half like the high school bar team could
hit a couple threes at the start of the
game and be leading but it's very
unlikely they're gonna beat lebron a
team of lebron
throughout two quarters right
so
good game your resigns well we'll check
with an engine obviously
but um
obviously this dude was legit
and we also want to check the opening to
see where i messed up
so we're not going to talk too deeply
about the
marshall itself because i had a previous
speedrun game you can look it up on
youtube where i played the marshall and
i talked a lot about the opening and the
origins of it and the ideas
um
so here we're going to go straight into
the theory so queen h3 bishop b3 ah
bishop f5 is wrong i completely
hallucinated the move is bishop g4 i'm
sorry queen d3
rook ae8
knight d2
rook e6
a4
and now there are several moves there's
f5 and queen h5 tremendously complex
opening
and the theory often goes to move 30 in
this line so you guys could definitely
do some research on your own you can go
to opening explore dig around
the other move in this position by the
way is rook e4
and here the main move is g5 this
is what i confused it with so g5 is a
move but it's here
and what's the point of bishop takes you
five who can tell me
bach thank you for the raid who can tell
me what black has a bishop takes g5
no but here you guys should understand
the idea of g5
here the idea of g5 is very simple is to
prevent rook h4
yeah four queen
f5 here the idea is to prevent rook h4
we want to keep the queen on h3 because
this is the main attacker
this is honestly not as crazy of a move
as you guys think it is
and and this relates to something i've
talked about quite a bit which is that i
i feel like chess coaches and chess
literature
uh tends to over
over i want to say over exaggerate i
guess just exaggerate
the like
what do i want to say
tends to exaggerate the effect of
pushing pawns in front of your own king
it's really not
often not as risky as
it's made out to be especially moving
the h pawn i've talked about that
you know like if the h pawn disappears
your king is often still safe especially
if the h file is inaccessible to white's
heavy pieces
but even often pushing the jeep on
can be fine sometimes you can tuck your
king away on h8
just something to to chew on
anyways bishop f5 is a mistake this is
embarrassing
bishop f5 is embarrassing i totally love
this queen e2
rookie a queen f1 but we've transposed
to actually a couple of games
yeah g5 is probably another bad move
an a4 is a typical rue lopez idea and i
was very impressed that my opponent knew
it thank you brownie
knight f4 let's check with an engine i'm
curious to see what the eval is at this
point
okay
so queen e2
rook aea queen f1 and h592
and g5 is not great and yeah a4 is
correct oh knight f4 is
huh knight f4 is actually second move
not not so bad knight f4
thank you faizal migel for the prime
bishop f4 gf
okay so rook
e8 rookie rookie one is good
rook d8
abab
bishop d1 is a
is a very good move as well
and g6 yeah i the white is just
consistently better here c5
maybe 5 is correct
everything our opponent is great this
just loses
rookie 8 check is a horrible blunder
white just has to play hg
and it's two pawns down for almost no
comp well there is some compensation you
can see the engine gives this
interesting sack on g3 which is what i
had initially intended
but i didn't see a follow-up here and i
felt like the king escapes via e2
which it does it's but it is a little
bit complicated it's only plus two
so
rook e8 is hasty
and again
not
not making automatic moves this i think
this moment really illustrates the
importance of that especially at this
level
a lot of people they look at this okay i
have to take the rook wait a minute
right you have to notice that you have
threats on the king's side
and white's bitten off more than he can
shoot king f1 the key though is bishop
d3 check this is the real winner without
this move
black would have been
at a loss because h1 queen doesn't do
anything queen g1 doesn't do anything
the king escapes lights up a rook
so bishop d3 is very important
so
well done to our opponent
again i
think a very high probability that he
played on his own
and
just knew
a lot of theory
but whatever it is um good stuff but
yeah the the key here is not to play
bishop f5 the move is bishop g4
no i don't think i don't think so i
think he played on his own
look it's hard to say
it's hard to say but i i think i think
just new theory
i want to give people the benefit of the
doubt
we're not for yeah this was a nice idea
i think
this is a nice idea this really
was a way to mix things up
look i i'm not an oracle i i don't know
for a fact
yeah well it's it's straight yeah yeah
that's the thing i mean you just don't
usually see
you know these ideas but
but then all of a sudden there was a
terrible blunder
anyways so that's that
bucko thank you everybody for hanging
out hope you enjoyed the stream have a
good one i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]